I just want to know you know your your
playing like real-life characters like
what kind of training research like how
do you really get into it do you want to
meet the people you're talking your
you're playing or you know not what to
do most definitely
you know me and break definitely spoke
on the phone a couple of times I was
underage so I couldn't go up there in
the state prison to go meet them myself
but you know I definitely feel like you
know we connect over the phone we talked
a lot of hours over the phone you know
how he called me on my off days he had
calls won't say you know we were just
showing my love and you know he's really
supportive and you know they were the
producers weren't in contact with the
real dawn while we were filming but and
I spoke to Rick a lot too and he just
told me loads of amazing stories and
anecdotes of him and his sister since
they were like really little like in the
good times and then also kind of more
horrific stories about her after her
drug addiction Wow yeah you really feel
how strong she is in this movie yeah
they're just great great before it sank
but I you know so you walk into over in
one day you go in for an audition a
screen test chemistry test boom there's
Matthew McConaughey what was that day
like you know before the screen then we
actually went bowling so we kind of got
to you know get a feel for each other
and you know it was like as soon as we
met each other it was like chemistry you
know I was calling them pops the very
first yeah I was just trying to get used
to it and you know it worked out really
good what was your score oh he beat me
you know I'm not gonna say he's a great
bowler but I'm not I'm not professional
myself I score like 52 oh wow
but yeah you know alright so so in terms
of like making you film like this what's
the hardest thing about about making a
film where you're juggling a lot because
there's there's the dynamic with the
family the dynamic with the drug dealers
with the FBI it's hard to know who to
trust and then and then you know your
your plate real life characters like
what was the hardest thing about making
like this making it true you know
actually taking yourself and putting
them into a real-life characters shoes
you know I feel like that was the
biggest part because it wasn't a made-up
character I felt like if those a made-up
character we would have had more
openness and more creativity it's not
that we didn't have but yeah more
freedom to do we want but since it was a
real life character we had to really
take his experiences in and everybody's
stories you know own a story exactly you
know you know with what playing with
playing a real life character I mean
especially I mean you know this is your
your first like major film but you know
you just like you're cool as a cucumber
you know both of you really making this
movie and there there's so much so much
to it what's the biggest sort of like
thing you learn about about filmmaking
humbleness you know how this industry
can eat people alive know staying humble
is of one big key and no creativity is
also and how amazing people actually are
you know you get 150 to 200 people on
set each day you know really hustling to
make this movie like the most insight
has the most amazing instincts like he's
the most unselfish act er I've ever
worked with which it was really useful
for Matthew and I and everyone else that
was it movie because he was so honest he
his choice was so honest and true just
did what he felt and that's why I think
the connections between all of the
family members feels so strong it was
definite he set the tone for that Bravo
my friend
you